hey my name is Hubert Davis from the
1993 New York Knicks and I play the role
of Dewey on the TV show duck tails how
you doing I'm Chris Sabo from the
Cincinnati Reds and I play Louie on duck
tails and we are gonna be talking about
our first time okay yes that's me first
time being an SNL said what was that one
the first time being on the SNL set what
was that like was that your audition
probably right yeah it was it was my
audition I remember then I didn't know
where I was but now I know cuz I was on
the show and I could remember things I
remember not walking through a door and
walking down an aisle that was just all
like red pipes and there was like paint
cans and wallpaper and now I realized
that was like where they build possess
but I just walked down this weird long
thing that was like where Emma turned
the corner and saw the set and was like
I had a bit for my audition where I was
gonna pop through the door for a second
and that was solely that if I didn't get
the show I could say like oh there was a
growler
did you do that character I got up on
the stage and I went oh gosh it's so far
away like it's so far away from the
front of things so I'm gonna have to run
and I got bailed on it and I didn't do
it Ben what's your first member from the
set of Parks and Recreation the first
day you just ask yourself a question I
did well you could have done I like the
move no I didn't know he just said read
the other one okay fine first memory on
parks recreation was I was just supposed
to be a tiny little seen me meeting Ron
Swanson and I remember getting to sit
and being in Swanson's office which was
very exciting and I remember being a
living nervous and then I did it once
and Mike Schur who created the show came
up to me and he said we're gonna bring
you live any way affect us oh I may be
very moving feel very confident and like
excited and then it would like and then
I remember doing it getting looser and
looser as I went I was very exciting
I miss that show very much I I do too
first big audition it's added
commercials or for Harold my powered
life for the upright citizens are going
to the soda guy was a big audition for
me it was me too maybe the most nervous
I've caused you you're taking these
classes you're spending so much time
with people and you look up to these
people that you're doing the auditions
for and you desperately want to get on a
team it was tough to us it was such as
the over
still yeah it's yeah there isn't a way
it is yeah but I mean like in 2003 it
was like we're in New York and we're
hustling and like you're watching Amy
Poehler on stage and Horatio and Tina
and all these incredible people that was
probably my I was so nervous for that
do you ever your big audition like
generation for the second Ninja Turtles
movie to be Rocksteady am I didn't get
it no use it not for the live-action one
yeah what was the first time you were
recognized in public Bobby like 20
minutes ago and it was me was weird it
was you each other for years look like a
Bobby boy don't want ease yeah you said
my name completely wrong I can tell a
story that happened to me today at Comic
Con
can't wait someone looking me in the
eyes and a crowd of people going Mandy
Mandy does not realize I've been
realizing that the thought of Mandy
Patinkin you saying that Letterman doors
oh sorry oh sorry first incorrect rumor
you read about yourself I was that I was
Christian know one of the first weeks I
was on SNL somebody was dating Lake Bell
at the time in Lakeville and we all
walked out of the party and the door
opened and I she was very nice and let
me help her so there was a picture in
the paper being Lake Bell it was like
his Lake Bell dating the new guy from
SNL loved it but it was the first time I
went like people cared like B that's
weird that people care about that stuff
because I don't what was your first ever
acting credit mine wasn't commercials
but first first real one was a New York
City serenade a movie that Chris Klein
and Freddie Prinze jr. and Frank Whaley
directed at this place so close
I was on an MTV commercial for that for
the show
rich girls with Tommy Hilfiger's
daughter was a reality show about Tommy
Hilfiger's daughter I was a guy on the
street a costing them and they never
said a word was like a
I'm a I'm a character I love that guy
yeah thanks first role you auditioned
for that you really wanted but didn't
get on solo on a new home I really want
to be hunt soul yeah and then some
carpenter got it but I really put my I
put my bones into that one Rocksteady
and Ninja Turtles really I was I mean
now you have to go with it from I'm
still really bummed about it every time
I see him I go I wish that guy that that
Rhino sounded like me I Edition for
fantastic beasts I really want to be in
that Oh Morgan Freeman's character in
Shawshank that's right you would have to
tell was supposed to be read first time
you were starstruck nah I remember
feeling I don't get starstruck anymore
and then Jim Carrey came in to host SNL
I know oh I'll go your story we'll get
to how he's his movie with Jim yeah it's
gonna be great man okay hold on a second
wait for the end of this thing I was
real I was like that's Jim Carrey I grew
up with him like it wait really after a
couple years on SNL I would like bow
yeah it was I remember being like that's
him and he's very Jim Carrey and awesome
I feel like there's a lot of people from
our youth that will see and also I feel
like when you've been doing this for a
while we've been doing it for a while
now that you kind of get you specially
every week you would have another it
wasn't a cenar but you kind of get used
to it but then I saw Stevie Wonder who
to me is like the bit like Stephen
wonders a steveland is to me I was so I
saw him but I couldn't like like nothing
we're oh I met jay-z once and I remember
shaking his hand and being like get
attitude you're wasting his time why
would he want to say hello to you in the
back of my head being like what do you
do and you so polite nice and in my head
but I was like why why would you why
would this wonderful man ever want to
talk to you first DuckTales memories for
me it's going home right after school to
David and Jose's house in the rocks and
we would eat macaroni and cheese and we
would watch duck tails and I loved it so
much and we would do our homework
afterwards or if there's a Disney
Afternoon commercial break it was his
name David and Jose his name is David
endo saying ba ba and Jo se god bless
you it's coming home from school for me
yeah yes please the tighter one through
here I hear that song and I think about
coming home from school
like relaxing when I hear that beam song
like craving English muffin with peanut
butter on that's what I do the last tip
or saying brother let's meet him bulb it
at the same time one two three first
chance could be the same thing first
rehearse the first kiss Allison Sinclair
is it true yeah it was like and I
believe Sandra patru sees house I think
that was it it was just like I'm and
that was it but like I think that was
like I went like I just kissed a girl oh
I remember when I went to Danielle
Avedon's
apartment and we in the Bronx are no
real pool you have to go to the pool but
we were swimming in her pool and my leg
touched her leg and I remember being
like oh it was a huge deal
legs touching I was like 25 at the time
what was yours first job President of
the United States oh that was Hugh was
my first job you were good that was a
New Deal all that stuff all that stuff
in New Deal was you all the laws you did
all of them build Oh Bobby's where
people gotta live the Constitution that
was here this is insane I'm gonna tell
the two things one my first job was I
was I was underage and I legally got
working papers somehow and I was a
janitor so I wasn't allowed to be a
counselor yet and I cleaned up all the
broken 40s this is real off the ground
so the kids when they come to camp could
play and not feel like they're gonna
because because people in Westchester
where we're both we spent a bunch of our
life they would drink and they would
throw their beer so I would be the one
that got gloves because I want mine to
be counsel yet I did that I made a movie
about it with Matt Damon what's it
called come on oh yeah then I saw the
math equations my first job was working
at a used toy store called play by play
really where was that I got paid and
used toys do you remember the one that
you really wanted that you got the GI
Joe hovercraft
oh that's a huge one though that was
expensive so couldn't afford exhaust
dirt-poor
and that's why I was working for free
toys I was 29 years
thank you we got more than enough
[Laughter]
[Music]